WINNIPEG CONNO
IN A ONE-TIME THAT'S THE NUMBER,
FORMER SHARK
NASH THE VETERAN, WITH A WRIST
SHOTT COMES BACK TO THE CENTER
THE FORMER VEGAS
THERE'S THE STAY BY HELLEBUYCK
AND THAT WILL BE KICKED UP AND
CLEARED DEEP IN TO REBOUND
>> PIERRE LU
LOOKS LIKE DUBOIS GOT TAKEN BAC
THE TAB AND HE IS STILL TICKED
TH LABANC
HAS 29 SECONDS O,
WINNIPEG
COGLIANO
S THAT GOOD LOOK BY COGLIANO,
LOOKING LIKE HE WANTS TO GO TO
THE DRIV
HE H H
JASPER WEATHERBY WEATHERBY,
HELLEBUYCK DEEP IN HIS NETD
HOME OPENER.AWAY, THREW A
SCREEN
DI
DILLON
STUCK WITH WITE GOING BACK TO T
POWER PLAY HERE.
>> IE CORNER FOR MEIER
BURNS.
>>> IF YOU ARE A SHARK FAN, YOU
ARE SITTING HIGHER IN YOUR S S Z
HIGHW
NY, BACK DOOR.
AND MIDDLETON, JOURNEY THATSO FR
HAG -- SIMEK,
TOO HARD
THAT GOE
EHLERS
IN FRONT, CONNOR DUMPS IT OUT
FRONT.
A SHOT BY HE WILING TO THREAD IT
OUT FRONT AND CONNOR TO YOUR
LEFT